but it's interesting do you find it
interesting how you write
songs and it's coming from i feel like a
lot of yours are personal like and then
and then people perceive them
differently like i'll be in like a meet
and greet and i'll be like oh wait what
and they'll think a song like i wrote
yeah the interpretation yes that happens
a lot i remember when i wrote a song
called hands clean someone came out to
me and they said um
i love that story you tell about this
where is you're in love with your
lesbian teacher and that song is so
beautiful the dedication to her is so
amazing and i just thought
did
[Laughter]
yeah is there some projection because
that's no one got that from that yeah
but the point of it is just that once i
mean when i write it for me it's
beautifully self-indulgent in a way
that's important for artists to do i
think yeah and then once i share it it's
yours to interpret as you wish and i'm
i'm always charmed by how people
interpret it because it's no longer
about me once they're listening yeah 100
yeah
[Music]